it was such a clear and definitive uh
powerful speech from President Biden who
has been just an incredible leader over
the last 11 days he was in command he
was strong he also was a comforter and
chief I thought it was very moving what
you saw tonight was a Savvy and
experienced president times like this I
look and say thank God Joe Biden's our
president not Donald
Trump the left is trying to paint Joe
Biden as a strong wartime president
after his Oval Office at dress last
night but in reality it was a total Miss
joining me now is Steven Miller founder
of America First legal and former senior
advisor to president Trump along with
Monica Crowley former assistant treasury
secretary in the Trump White House
Stephen what speech were they
watching not the same speech that you
and I and the rest of America was
watching the President portrayed
weakness that is the fundamental image
that came across to the millions of
people both watching it here and around
the globe Amica American citizens are
being taken hostage by Hamas they are
the prisoners of Hamas they have been
brutalized they have been murdered they
have been subjected to hores that we
cannot even imagine instead of instead
of looking into that camera and saying
do not touch a hair on their head do not
hurt our people don't you dare you will
regret it for a thousand lifetimes
instead of that he gave some speech
about islamophobia and how we have to be
nicer to everybody and how we all have
to show restraint it was an
embarrassment well I couldn't agree with
you more on the right side of the screen
you can see Air Force One uh the
president is uh is leaving uh he's about
to go to reoboth beach all right Monica
um you know Biden did mention Iran's
connection to boss but only briefly take
a
listen Iran is is is supporting Russ
Russia's in Ukraine and it's supporting
Hamas and other terrorist groups in the
region and will continue to hold them
accountable I might add is that supposed
to sound forceful it almost sounded like
a footnote mentioned in
passing yeah I mean what does that even
mean the American president is sitting
there while we've got American hostages
on the ground uh in Israel we've got
Americans In Harm's Way uh thanks to his
weakness and uh you know the state
department just issued a worldwide
caution for American citizens around the
world and he's saying that he's going to
hold Iran accountable nobody knows what
that means he did not articulate that
the President should have laid out a
very aggressive agenda of exactly how he
is going to hold Tyron accountable and
instead you know what he is doing is the
exact opposite he is fully committed to
resurrecting the Iran nuclear deal which
is incredibly destructive dangerous and
destabilizing to the region and the
world and he also remains committed to
enriching Iran through lack sanctions
enforcement so he can talk all day long
about accountability for Iran but its
actions show the exact opposite it shows
empowering Iran which is behind all of
these attacks and is the largest state
sponsor of Terror and has been for 40
years Stephen you know um I want you to
take a listen to this sound about uh uh
the Muslim Community being
frustrated
I know many of you in the Muslim
American Community the Arab American
Community the Palestinian American
community and so many others are
outraged and harded saying to yourselves
here we go again with islamophobia and
distrust we saw after 9/11 we must
without equivocation denounce
anti-Semitism we must also without
equivocation denounce
islamophobia did the president talk
enough about the the children the
victims of October
7th no of course he didn't and I want to
return again to this point Hamas has
spilled American blood they do not take
this President seriously they do not
take this country seriously their
leaders are just chilling out in Cutter
having the time of their lives sipping
champagne living in their fancy
compounds having T course meals loving
life they have absolutely zero fear of
the repercussions of taking American
lives I'm not talking about fighting a
war I'm not talking about nation
building I'm talking about preventing
foreign terrorists from murdering our
people president Trump used to say when
he was in the White House you murder our
people and your life is forfeit your
life is forfeit instead all around the
world people think you can kidnap
imprison torture rape murder and Ma
Americans and all you'll get is more
money from Uncle Sam straight to Iran
and straight into the terrorist Pockets
straight to Gaza straight to Hamas this
is a tremendous embarrassment and
debasement and humiliation for this
country you know uh Monica you were uh
in the treasury Department we know that
Donald Trump cut off the money we know
that Joe Biden turned the spet back on
what what should be done at this point
to
Iran well if you want to cut off the
head of the snake you go directly to
Tyran and you do cut off the money this
Administration so far has unfrozen about
10 billion dollars everybody's focused
on the six billion sitting in Cutter um
which the administration refuses to move
on but since Joe Biden became president
he has unfrozen about 10 billion on top
of that because its Administration has
refused to forcefully uh enforce the
sanctions against Iran they've enriched
Iran to the tune of about 80 billion
dollar by allowing them to make that
money in oil profits exactly so if you
want to cut the head off the snake you
have to stop the money flow and this
Administration refuses to do it because
they're absolutely committed to
resurrecting the Iran nuclear deal which
was Obama's big Legacy item incredibly D
destructive to the region and the world
but they are intent to do it so they
don't want to do anything that's going
to alienate the Iranians even in the
face of this massive massacre in Israel
it is amazing uh panel thanks so much
for being with us this evening hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else